the housing market has been crazy as of
late the question is
will it continue recently i spoke with
real estate expert jared urane
about that jared the numbers have been
amazing here
as far as home sales what have you been
hearing what have you seen
well thanks kendall we are in a new
month and things are progressing
uh as we intend them we want our
inventory levels to move forward but
really the question for sellers today is
do you want a crazy offer on your house
nationwide inventory levels are still
tight
locally they're still at a half percent
the the rate for mortgages is still
around three percent so our buyer demand
hasn't changed
so it's kind of more the same thing at
the moment but we are headed in the
right direction as far as our inventory
goes
but back to that question do you want a
crazy offer on your house
name your price we're getting the
highest price guaranteed every time
uh if you're not you need to be talking
to the right person yeah and if you sell
your home though then the question is
where do you go because you're going to
pay a
crazy price somewhere and that comes
down to a lot of people are offering
over appraised values and the question
then
is is that a good idea or should you
just waive the appraisal altogether
yeah that's that's uh a feature that
we've been seeing quite a bit
in the offers here's the bottom line if
it is a financed
offer you are going to get an appraisal
period
the bank needs that there's no question
about it so how are buyers doing it well
there's
typically two ways very few lenders will
offer
occasionally in very rare instances a
waived appraisal that's usually based on
the buyers
situation or their fico score but more
than likely what the buyers are doing is
they are simply accelerating the
appraisal timeline
within the buyer's due diligence period
now it's a nice technique and it works
really well because it gives the buyer
an opportunity to get all the
information and then decide whether or
not they want to proceed
but the caution item for the seller on
this case is
make sure that you get your due
diligence make sure you understand that
the lender
knows what they're doing and that you
will proceed to close otherwise you're
going to
end up losing that deal and lowering the
price because it just doesn't look
attractive so far so
it's a neat technique but uh you got to
be careful careful with it
it's hard to know what to do right now
and how does someone if they're just
looking for
an affordable home find that yes well
this is where we get to open up our
entire tool bag of options right
if you're a buyer and you're really
trying to find that one gem that new
home that you're looking for
consider homes that have been on the
market for at least two weeks or more
even a month
or ones that have tenants in them you
might find one where their lease is
coming up and you'll be able to get a
great deal on those items
another one is find one that needs work
you can
package in repairs into the financing of
your purchase
townhomes are another alternative option
to really consider you still get all the
great amenities of the house
and condos of course being one of the
hot topics many people are looking
towards right now
the only caution with condos is make
sure that they are qualified for your
financing type because not every condo
community does qualify for
all types but many different ways you
can you can slice down
you can get a lot more information by
giving palacios realty a call that phone
number 702-333-6666 or
heading to their website they have a
special offer for you one percent
contribution
toward your closing cost purchase when
you sell with palacio's realty